Good morning, class.  Nice to see you here,
you loyal holdouts, the stalwarts who haven't gone home early for
Thanksgiving.  You recall that last time we were talking about the
Matevoidic system,  and much of the rationale for
studying it stems from two reasons.  First of all, it recapitulates in a
formal sense what happens during embryogenesis,
i.e. one has relatively undifferentiated stem cells which
are able to differentiate into a number of different directions by
committing themselves to either the myeloid or lymphoid compartment,
and then going down yet other pathways, more detailed pathways to
generate a whole variety of cell types.
Secondly, we really understand the differentiation pathways of
Matevoisis better than we understand any tissue in the body,
in no small part because it's much easier to study the soluble cells in
the blood and in the immune system than it is to study how these
processes happen in normal tissues.  But having said that,
I want to emphasize the fact that in each of our tissues there are
oligopotential stem cells.  When I say oligopotential I mean
they can go down several different pathways.  Recall up there on that
diagram we talked about pluripotential which means multiple,
and today we're going to talk a bit about todipotential stem cells,
which are able to disperse descendants into all the different
differentiation lineages in the body.
At the end of our last lecture,  we were focusing on the red blood
cells.  And this is sometimes called erythropoiesis,
which is to say the process by which red blood cells are generated.
We mentioned the concept of homeostasis, and homeostasis just
refers to the fact that all of these systems are in very delicate balance
so that the body can respond to the physiologic needs of the organism at
any one point in time.  We talked about the fact that for
example when there's a massive infection in the body,
then the homeostatic mechanisms allow an increase in these kinds of
immune cells in order to encounter the infection.
And at the end of our last lecture,  we were talking about this specific
branch, and how in fact homeostasis is maintained there.
And what we see here is a series of committed progenitors.
So when I talk about committed progenitors I'm referring to cells
that have already made the commitment to go down one
or another pathway.  They're not yet fully differentiated.
As you can see here,  we have first forming cells and
colony forming cells.  We don't need to remember all the
different abbreviations except to say that these cells here are in a
relative undifferentiated state.  And the only end stage
differentiation comes at the very end here when we get to red blood
cells.  We said in general that it's the case that most highly
differentiated cells are post-mitotic, which is to say
they're never going to reenter into the growth and division cycle of the
cell that we talked about earlier in the semester.
And that's obviously dictated here by the fact that this erythrocyte
lacks a nucleus,  i.e. during the final stage of
differentiation,  in addition to accumulating large
amounts of hemoglobin in its cytoplasm, this cell actually pops
out its nucleus,  and that obviously represents an
irrevocable change in that cell can never again enter into growth
and division cycle.  The immediate precursor of an
erythrocyte is often called an erythroblast.  And the term blast
here refers to a cell of embryonic appearance.  Blast is used often to
indicate, we'll mention that again shortly, a cell which looks very
primitive, and embryonic,  and undifferentiated.  And that ends
up going into an erythrocyte,  which we said is actually a synonym
for a red blood cell, an RBC, a red blood cell.
And we talked about the fact that this progression is actually
maintained and furthered by the stimulus of the compound called
erythropoietin.  So, we're using some of the same
words over and over again.  And erythropoietin is essentially a
growth factor which stimulates the end stage differentiation of the
erythroblast into the erythrocyte.
Epo, as erythropoietin's often abbreviated, is actually made in the
kidneys.  And it's made in the kidneys in response to the
physiological stimulus of hypoxia.  Hypoxia means inadequate
oxygenation of the tissues.  You might ask, well, why is red
blood cell contractions controlled,  as they are, in the kidney?
And the fact is,  we don't really know why evolution
has chosen the kidney as the site of monitoring the degree of oxygenation
of the blood.  And in response to hypoxia, it begins to crank out
erythropoietin,  or Epo.  You can think of
erythropoietin as an extracellular liggon just like a growth factor.
It has its own cognate receptor on the surface of the erythroblast,
and when Epo released by the kidney hits an erythroblast in the context
of the bone marrow,  it actually has two effects.
It happens to be the case that roughly even 95% of the erythroblast
that are made routinely are forced to go into apitosis under routine
conditions.  So,  this is an enormously wasteful
system, i.e. as every moment we speak, 90 or 95% of the erythroblast
that have come into existence in your bone marrow apitose.
They never go into end stage differentiation.
But when Epo is around,  Epo provides a strong anti-apoptotic
signal to the red blood saves some and maybe even all of the
erythroblasts from their normal fate of undergoing apitosis.
So here, if we imagine there are actually two fates,
one is to become an erythrocyte,  and the other is to apitose, where
the aptisosis is paradoxically enough the dominant fate of the cell,
the moment that an Epo comes on the scene, it blocks this alternative
fate, allowing these cells to mature.  Epo at the same time stimulates the
erythroblast to differentiate.  Now, you might as yourself the
question, why is there this enormously inefficient process?
An enormous effort is made to crank out large, astronomical numbers of
erythroblasts,  and yet most of them are wasted even
before they've had a chance to undergo end stage differentiation.
And the rationale here is as follows.  This is a terrific system
for rapidly ramping up the level of red blood cells in your circulation
because here, within a matter of a day or two, one can crank up,
actually in a matter of hours,  you can crank up the rate of
production of red blood cells by maybe even a factor of ten.
Instead of having 90% of the erythroblast apitose,
let's say 0% of them do so,  and therefore, instead of having 10%
of the erythroblasts becoming red blood cells, 100% of them will do so.
And therefore,  you have the virtually miraculous
response that if you go from here high up in the rocky mountains at
ten or 12,000 feet,  within a matter of two or three days,
your red blood cell concentration actually has compensated,
has risen up to create the oxygen caring capacity that enables you to
deal with the thin oxygen,  with the low oxygen tension that's
present at high altitudes.  Now, having said that,
the fact is that there is an Epo receptor on the surface of the
erythroblast, and what we see there is the following.
Let's talk about the erythroblast and just blow it up a little bit.
So, here's the erythroblast.  That's the undifferentiated
precursor.  And by the way,  the erythroblast is actually still a
white blood cell.  Often we call a white blood cell a
leukocyte.  You may know that gluco means white.  So,
a leukocyte, it's still white.  And after the erythropotent
impinges on it,  one of the things it starts doing is
to make the hemoglobin,  which turns it into a red blood cell.
At this stage, it's still white.  On the surface of the erythroblast
are these Epo receptors.  I'll just abbreviate them like this,
Epo receptor, and once it binds the liggon Epo just like the growth
factor receptors,  we talked early in the receptors
signals are sent into the erythroblast to stimulate both
differentiation and to prevent the initiation of the cell suicide
program that we call apitosis.  Interestingly, one of the things
that happens normally is the following, that when these signals
come in, there is an enzyme called a phosphotase which is attracted
to the receptor.  The Epo receptor works like a
tyrosine kinase growth factor receptor that we talked about
earlier in the semester.  And here, we have an enzyme,
a phosphotase, which actually counteracts the function of the
tyrosine kinases.  So, after the Epo receptor has
bound its liggon,  here's the plasma membrane,
it has a whole series of I'll draw Y here for tyrosine.
It has a whole series of phosphates attached to it because of the
actions of tyrosine kinase enzymes that are associated with its
cytoplasmic domain indirect analogy to what we talked about in the case
of growth factor receptors.  But, one of the things that happens
is that this phosphotase,  which removes phosphates, then gloms
onto the receptor like this.  It grabs hold of some of these
tyrosine kinases.  And what this phosphotase does is
reach around.  It reaches around and it begins to prune off all of these
phosphates because that's what a phosphate does.
It cuts away all the phosphates,  thereby directly reversing the
previous actions of the tyrosine kinase that led to the formation of
these phosphates,  and that in turn allows downstream
signaling to occur.  This is obviously a functional
negative feedback loop,  i.e. whenever there is an agonist
you want an antagonist.  Whenever there's a stimulus which
is induced in the body,  there has to be an inhibitory signal,
and this is part of the whole issue of homeostasis,
the balance between forward and backward.  Interestingly enough,
there's a family in Finland, I believe, which has a mutant receptor.
And their mutant receptor lacks this tyrosine.
And what happens as a consequence is that that particular tyrosine
doesn't get phosphorolated.  Because that tyrosine doesn't get
phosphorolated,  the phosphotase cannot be attracted
to the receptor because there isn't a tyrosine there.
There's some other amino acid residue.  I don't know what it is.
It's not important, but it's not a tyrosine.  And this cannot happen
because they don't have this tyrosine.  This phosphotase could
not be attracted to the receptor to shut it down as it normally
would be.  So normally homeostasis is
imbalanced, and several members of this family have become Olympic
cross-country ski winners.  They've become Olympic champions.
Why?  Because their Epo receptor's hyperactive.  Because the Epo
receptor's hyperactive,  they have higher than normal levels
of red blood cells in the circulation, and this clearly allows
them to function better in cross country skiing,
which as you know is a really physically demanding task.
Again, I'm not saying this is a good thing for them necessarily.
There are other things in life besides, believe it or not,
winning cross country Olympic competitions because as I mentioned
last time, having too many red blood cells in your circulation,
there's a downside to it which is that you have a much greater
tendency to have occlusions,  to have blood clots in your
circulation which obviously is not a very good thing to have.
Oh, so is there a threshold of Epo
receptor activation before phosphotase shuts it down?
These things are not really well understood, are not well studied.
The fact is, you might be able to say we should make a mathematical
model of all of these different circuitry.  But the fact is if you
want to make a mathematical model,  you have to know some of the
constants.  You have to know some of the parameters, the binding
constants.  And in fact, for most of the
signaling interactions,  no one's ever really studied them in
such great detail.  So, one really doesn't know how
much phosphate you need here before the phosphotase becomes really
active.  And so,  there's not a really good
mathematical model of this feedback loop, even though we know without
any doubt that it exists.  So, I want to get into other issues
that are related to the whole issue of accumulated differentiation
traits as one moves down this pathway.
Again, we've used this as a model for how differentiation takes place
in the entire body.  The faith that's been implicit in
this kind of scheme for the last 20 or 30 years is that this acquisition
of different kinds of phenotypes is not accompanied by genetic changes,
that is, in the genomes of these cells.  I.e. one can accomplish
these different kinds of differentiation not by rearranging
genes but just by rearranging transcriptional programs,
and that the DNA sequence of these cells as they proliferate and
differentiate is fully unchanged.  And that's a matter of faith
because you could say to me,  how do you know that it's really
true.  The fact is that people have looked at genes in many kinds of
cell types, but it's essentially impossible, or it has been at least
until recently,  to preclude the possibility that as
cells move down these differentiation pathways,
they begin to change the nucleotide sequences of different
ones of their genes.  In fact, I've already told you about
one instance where that's clearly the case.  And that is in the
differentiation of the B cells of the immune system,
which happen to be right up here on this chart, because as you recall
from our discussion vis-Ä-vis immunology, the B cells actually do
rearrange their genes in order to cobble together DNA sequences that
together are able to enable them to make antibodies that are able to
react to specific antigens.  So there, there's no doubt at all
that there's a somatic rearrangement of the genes, somatic meaning it's
not a germ line change.  It's happening in the soma outside
of the germ line.  There's a somatic mutation.
It's not a mutation that's deleterious, but rather is directed
towards a physiologically normal and desirable end point.
But for example, how do you know that when you remember things in the
brain, part of the memory does not derive from changing the DNA
sequence and different neurons in the brain?
What's the molecular basis of memory?  Could it be that each time we learn
some things that there are different nucleotide sequences,
critical nucleotide sequences,  that are changed in neurons in the
brain, and that those nucleotide sequence changes represent an
important basis for ensuring that memory is retained over decades of
time.  Or, rather than having genetic changes in the brain,
might it all be epigenetic, i.  . all the other changes that happen
to the cell besides changing DNA sequences in the chromosomal DNA.
So, here we're dealing with the dialectic between epigenetic and
genetic.  And,  have we talked about DNA methylation
here?  Yes, so we talked about DNA methylation, and do you recall or
having discussed the fact that when DNA gets methylated,
that suppresses the transcription of a gene.
But that doesn't change the nucleotide sequence,
and that methylation configuration of a gene can be passed to one cell
generation to the next.  It's heritable, but it's not
genetic in the strictest sense of the term, i.e.
it doesn't involve a change in nucleotide sequence,
which is what we want to limit this term to referring.
So, epigenic can represent all the changes in the cell including DNA
methylation, alterations in transcription,
and all other downstream events that result in changes in the cell.
And how can one address this?  Well,  there are different ways of
addressing this question or addressing the possibility that in
fact there are changes in the nucleotide sequence of the gene.
One way to do this is the following.  And that is to take cells from an
early embryo, and here we see an early vertebrate embryo.
This looks really more like a frog embryo or a slightly different shape,
and here we see an early embryo.  It's after a blastula.  It's called
a blastocyst.  Here again we have the word blast.
How about one question per lecture?  We have to have some equity here.
Other people can ask questions.  It's good to ask questions,
but how about one per lecture; that's fair, equitable.
All right, so here's an early vertebrate embryo.
Here we see the blastocyst.  This comes after the earlier stages
in the embryo,  and here we see the inner cell mass.
And as it turns out, the inner cell mass is going to be the precursor of
many of the tissues of the ultimately arising embryo.
And here, one can do an interesting experiment.  One can take cells out
of the inner cell mass.  And one can begin to propagate them
in culture.  And what one ends up with is embryonic stem cells.
And the intrinsic interest of embryonic stem cells is manifold.
For one thing, you can take embryonic stem cells and you can
genetically alter them.  You can put a new gene in,
in the case of a mouse, or you can take another gene out.
And then what you can do is you can inject the genetically altered
embryonic stem cell into the blastocyst of another embryo.
So let's say we take the cells out of the inner cell mass.
We develop embryonic stem cells.  We can call them ES cells.  That's
what they're called in the trade,  ES cells.  We take them out.  We can
propagate them in culture.  And then, what we can find is we'll
put a genetic marker in those ES cells.  Let's say we put in those
embryonic stem cells the marker for the gene beta-galactosidase.
And beta-galactosidase in the presence of a proper indicator,
if you put a proper indicator and make a cell turn blue.
So now we have an ES cell line that produces the beta-galactosidase
enzyme.  The beta-galactosidase enzyme beta-gal itself has no effect
on the biology of the cells.  It's only a marker.  And now,
we take those ES cells, and we inject them into another embryo,
a wild type embryo that lacks this beta-gal marker.
And what we can see is that we inject the ES cells into this
blastocyst.  The injected ES cells will now insinuate themselves,
will now intrude into the massive cells in this embryo into which we
injected the ES cells,  and they will become part of the
entire embryo genesis that follows.  I.e. soon these foreign ES cells
will weasel their way into this inner cell mass.
And they will become established and become functionally equivalent to
the inner cell mass cells that were resident there prior to this
injection.  And what you can do then is follow the subsequent fate of,
in this case, a mouse.  And what will happen often is that you can
find blue cells all over the mouse sometimes in the paws,
sometimes in the coat.  Let's imagine that the hair would turn
blue, which in fact is not the case.  But let's imagine the hair would
turn blue.  So here's the mouse,
happy because it's part of an important experiment.
And what you'll sometimes see is that, well, remember that art was
not my forte.  Anyhow,  here you might see stripes of blue
cells on the skin.  The hair won't turn blue actually,
but the skin may if you give it the proper indicator.
And what this indicates is that in this case, the cells that were
injected into the blastocyst could become part of lineages which
committed themselves to becoming skin cells.
Or, the cells in the brain might be blue.  Or, the cells in the gut
might be blue.  Or under certain conditions,
the cells in the intestine might be blue.  In telling you that,
I mean to indicate that the cells that we injected into this
blastocyst, which carry beta-gal were totipotent.
They could create all the tissues of the mouse under the proper
conditions.  The proper conditions are obviously being put into this
very special environment in which all kinds of differentiation
inducing signals,  which we don't really understand,
can induce this cell to commit itself to enter into one or another
differentiation lineage.  And in principal, you can make a
whole organism out of an ES cell.  ES cell has as much plasticity, as
much flexibility, as a fertilized egg.
It has not yet lost the ability to make all the parts of the body.
On some occasions, the ES cell will even get into the gonads of the
mouse, which are down here somewhere.  And if that's so,
if the ES cell which you injected has been able to seed the formation
of these cells down here,  then what will happen is that either
the sperm or the egg coming from this mouse will now transmit
the blue gene.  And now, in the next generation,
all of the mice will inherit the blue beta-galactosidase gene in all
of their cells because now this will have entered into the germ line.
If these blue cells happen to colonize the testes,
the ovary, or the testes,  then these blue cells will become
ancestors to the sperm or the egg.  And now, in the next generation,
mice will inherit a blue gene in all of their cells.
And now this mouse is really happy because it's now part of an
extremely important experiment because now all of its cells will
become blue, having inherited them as part of the oocyte which led to
its formation.  In this kind of an animal,
we call this animal a kind of a chimera.  Chimera is a mythical
beast which is,  let's say, half human and half horse
or something like that.  Or a chimera means it has
genetically different parts in it.  That is not to say that these parts
carrying the blue gene are necessarily defective,
they're just genetically different,  one from the other.  But they can
participate in embryogenesis in a fashion that's indistinguishable
from the non-blue cells.  They just do everything they're
supposed to do,  and they pretend as if they were in
this embryo from the get go,  from the very beginning, from the
moment of fertilization.  So they are totipotent.
There's an alternative experiment you can do, and you can take the ES
cells, and you can inject them under the skin of a mouse,
let's say.  So now, you're putting them in a very unfamiliar
environment.  And what you see then on many occasions is you can
actually get a tumor.  You can get what's called an
embryonal carcinoma.
Now you'll say,  well, so what?  That's not so
interesting.  But it's very interesting.  Why?
Because if you look at the genome of those embryonal carcinoma cells
which we can call EC cells if you want, those cells are genetically
full wild type.  And yet, we're getting a tumor here.
So, it means that these cells,  which have been placed in a fully
unfamiliar environment under the skin or in the belly of a mouse will
begin to form a tumor.  And in fact, they represent the
only type of cell that we know about where a cell having a wild type
genome can actually give you a tumor.
As you sensed from our previous discussions, all other kinds of
human cancer cells we know about have to have mutant genes in order
for them to grow as a malignancy.  These cells are fully wild type and
can grow as an embryonal carcinoma.  They are very primitive.  These
cells have quite a bit of autonomy.  They're not so responsive to all
the growth factors that normally are required by many cells throughout
the soma of an animal throughout the tissues.
So this allows us to begin to move on and ask other kinds of questions.
For example, you can take these embryonal carcinoma cells.
You put them in a Petri dish,  and you can actually induce them to
differentiate into different cell types in vitro.
How can you do that?  Well, we're just beginning to learn
how to do that.  We don't really know how to do that.
But, if you give them the right cocktail of growth factors,
they might begin to form muscle cells.  If you give them another
cocktail of growth factors,  they might begin to give pancreatic
eyelid cells that form insulin,  or in this case cartilage cells.
And presumably, the cocktail of growth factors you're providing each
one of these cells with in vitro,  i.e. in the Petri dish, is mimicking
the growth factor environment that each of these cell types is
experiencing within the embryo.  In other words,
cells in different parts of the embryo experience different
combinations of growth factors that persuade them to commit themselves
to becoming these kind of cells,  these kind of cells, and these kind
of cells.  And therefore,  one of the promises of embryonic
stem cell research is the possibility of being able to
regenerate different kinds of tissues in a fashion that I just
showed you here.  But this whole experiment in the
case of human beings is ethically extremely controversial.
Why?  Because the experiment starts out making these ES cells here,
and if we want to start out with an early embryo like this,
start out with a blastocyst,  in the case of a human blastocyst,
this human blastocyst has the potential under the proper
conditions of becoming a newborn human being.  And therefore,
we have this enormous ethical conflict in this country.
Is this blastocyst already a human being?  Can you already afford to
truncate the life of this blastocyst at this stage of development,
and in so doing, are you actually extinguishing human life,
or is this organism, if you want to call it that, already still much too
primitive to consider it to be equal to human life?
And here, I would not,  unlike my political views,
be forward enough to venture an opinion because it's really
something that no one really can argue about in any objective way.
It's all a matter of opinion.  Is this a human being already,
or is it simply an inanimate cluster,  a clump of cells?
Now, in principal,  how could we do this?
How could we actually create this kind of tissue therapy?
Because the fact is, as you get older, your tissues start falling
apart.  You haven't experienced that.
But I have.  And the fact is that even if you try to stay in shape,
things just start falling apart.  And the older you get,
the more they fall apart.  Even people who eat well,
which I do, and exercise well,  which I don't, even they fall apart.
And so the question is, are there way of replacing and repairing
tissue?  And this would,  in principal, represent one such
strategy because it means that you could possibly inject replacement
cells into an agent tissue and generate cells which could then
restore and regeneration function which has somehow inevitably
deteriorated over the decades.  Well, that raises the question of
how you can actually get a blastocyst, how you can make a
blastocyst like this.  To state an obvious thing which you
might already have intuited,  let's say you had such cells
differentiated from various cell types that you want to inject into
somebody's muscle or into their liver if they had diabetes and had
lost their beta cells,  or into their cartilage if they
banged up their knee during basketball practice or something
like that, or jogging,  which is allegedly good for you.
Who knows?  How could you deal with that?  Well, the fact is,
let's imagine there were such a blastocyst which we'd produce in
this fashion that we differentiated like this.
OK, this is now the sequence of events.  There's an important
consideration we have to take into account, and that is if this
blastocyst came from a different person than you,
and we induced these cells to differentiate,
and we injected those differentiation cells into your
muscle, things wouldn't work.  Why?  Because these cells, if the
blastocyst originated in a different person than yourself would be
genetically different from you,  and would be recognized as foreign
tissue by your immune system.  So even though you were getting an
injection of cells which could regenerate your muscle perfectly
well, those cells would never be given a chance to establish
themselves and to thrive,  and to reconstruct the tissue simple
because the immune system would regard those cells as being
foreigners and would go after them hammer and tongs trying to get rid
of them in the same way it tries to get rid of all kinds of foreign
invaders.  I.e.  the only way you could avoid it is
if this blastocyst was genetically identical to you.
But how can you make a blastocyst which is genetically identical to
you?  Well, I'm glad I asked that question.  That's really the big
challenge we have here because we don't want to create a situation
where we have to restore somebody's tissues, but the only way we can
restore them is to leave them immunosuppressed for the rest of
their lives.  When I say immunosuppressed I mean we have to
prevent their immune system from attacking all of these cells that
we've injected in them,  these foreign cells, in the same way
that we have to suppress the immune system of any person who has
received a graft from another individual including often bone
marrow transplants.  In all cases, we have at least for a
while to prevent their immune system from attacking and eliminating these
engrafted cells.  And this is where the whole strategy
comes for the whole process of cloning.  You may recall the case of
Dolly about five years ago,  and let's remember what happened
here because this would a momentous experiment in mammalian biology.
It asked the question, really, if you take cells from a somatic tissue,
from here, or here,  or here, are those cells,
in principal, still totipotent,  i.e. is the nucleus, is the genome
of those cells totipotent,  or has the genome, the chromosomal
complement of cells in their cells undergone some kind of irrevocable,
irreversible change, which precludes those cells from ever
becoming totipotent?  Well, in fact,
if you take mammary epithelial cells from the breast of a human being or
from the breast of a ewe and you put them into the blastocyst,
nothing's going to happen.  Those introduced mammary epithelial
cells will not be able to establish themselves in the blastocyst.
And, we will not be able to insinuate themselves amidst the
inner cell mass,  and they will not be able to
participate in embryogenesis.  So therefore, the epigenetic program
in these somatic cells seems to be irrevocably set to preclude the
participation of the already differentiated mammary epithelial
cells in subsequent embryogenesis.  Therefore, you could not do this
experiment all over again of introducing cells into the inner
cell mass as I just described over here, injecting them into this.
But still, that doesn't answer the question.  The issue is not whether
the mammary epithelial cell is irrevocably committed to being a
mammary epithelial cell.  The issue: is its genome capable
under the proper circumstances of becoming an early embryonic cell.
And therefore, what was done is the following.  One took mammary
epithelial cells,  in this case from Dolly's quote
unquote "mother,  one prepared nuclei from these
cells, taking them out of the cytoplasm, and then one got
fertilized eggs or eggs that have been induced to become.
So here's an oocyte.  An oocyte is an unfertilized egg.
In principle, you can activate an oocyte by putting a sperm in,
or in fact it's actually better if you take the oocyte and you fool it
into thinking it's become fertilized by treating it with different salts,
high potassium concentration, and so forth.
And that will induce the egg to say I've been fertilized.
I better start embryogenesis.  But what you do in this case is the
following.  The egg has its own haploid nucleus here,
and you can take a little needle.  And, you suck that nucleus right
out of the egg.  So, you've enucleated it.
That's what you've done, and now the egg is enucleate.
It doesn't have a nucleus in it.  But keep in mind,
much of what happens during early embryogenesis is programmed not only
by the genes but by all array of cytoplasmic proteins that are
present throughout the egg,  and which play critical roles in
determining the subsequent course of embryogenesis.
So now what you can do is you inject into this enucleate oocyte
the nucleus of a mammary epithelial cell.
The mammary epithelial cell is obviously highly differentiated.
It's there to make milk.  We'll call it an MEC if you want,
and you put that in there, and under certain circumstances,
and then you can treat this with a little bit of salt to mimic the
physiological stimulus that comes after the sperm hits the egg.
And now this egg will think it's been fertilized.
And now it will begin to divide.  But keep in mind, the genome of
this quote unquote "unfertilized egg" has come not from the sperm and
the preexisting nucleus of the egg.  It's come because the nucleus has
been injected from a mammary epithelial cell.
An experience over the last 30 years had indicated that this will
never work.  But finally somebody in Scotland, a man named Ian Wilmouth
tinkered enough with the conditions of these cells that he could
actually get it to work not so often,  maybe one, or two,
or three times out of 100 tries.  But on those conditions,
this thing would begin to divide.  The nucleus would begin to divide
its diploid.  Keep in mind that when a sperm comes into an egg,
the egg is haploid.  The sperm is haploid.  Together they make a
diploid genome.  This introduced genomus diploid,
and the question is, the critical question is, can the genes in this
introduced nucleus totally rearrange their transcriptional program so
that even though these genes might all be intact in terms of nucleotide
sequence, can the entire infinitely complex array of DNA associated
proteins,  I.e. the proteins that constitute
the chromatin which is not only the histones but also the transcription
factors, the TF's,  can they all jump on and jump off as
they should to mimic and replicate the spectrum of transcription
factors that is normally present shortly after an egg is fertilized?
If they can do that,  then this embryo can begin to
replicate, and can ultimately develop into a complete embryo.
If they can't, then embryogenesis is going to be truncated shortly
thereafter maybe at the two cell stage, at the four cell stage,
at the 16 cell stage, but shortly thereafter, not because of the DNA
sequences being defective,  but because the spectrum of
transcription factors is up and down regulates certain genes is in fact
not been able to re-assort themselves in response to what?
Initially, in response to the signals coming from the cytoplasm
because one might imagine,  correctly so, that the nucleus in
here is getting signals from the cytoplasm telling it,
in effect, telling this nucleus,  you should behave functionally as if
you were the nucleus of a fertilized egg.  In other words,
the environment of proteins here is influencing the behavior
of this nucleus.  That goes backwards to our normal
way of thinking because keep in mind our normal vectoral way of thinking
is that the nucleus is influencing the cytoplasm.
That's the direction of information flow.  But here,
we're having a different situation.  Here, the cytoplasm is telling this
injected nucleus,  well, you used to be a mammary
epithelial cell nucleus,  but now you've got to take on a
different job.  And we're going to force you to do
so.  And to the extent that happens,
then in principle, one can end up having a normal embryo.
And, it happened actually on rare occasion that this worked.
Here they used actual electrical stimulus rather than salt to get the
nucleus to divide.  This electrical stimulus,
again, was to mimic the stimulus that the sperm entering the egg
normally provides,  thereby activating the egg and
forcing the entire fertilized egg to proliferate.
And so, once this starts developing,  let's say, the blastocyst stage,
here we have a blastocyst.  You can see the inner cell mass
once again here.  This can be transferred into a
pseudo-pregnant ewe.  Pseudo-pregnant means you take a
female ewe and you inject it with a series of hormones that persuade her
reproductive system including prolactin, and progesterone,
or estrogen, persuade her reproductive system,
her uterus, that she's pregnant.  You inject this early embryo into
her, and this early embryo will then implant into the wall of her uterus
and begin to develop.  And if it all works well,
you get a Dolly is born.  You get a new sheep coming out of this.
It doesn't work so often, one,  two, three, four times after out of
a hundred, and very often in the great majority of cases,
there are mis-births, mis-carriages,  which happen in the middle of
embryogenesis.  So, almost in the great majority of
cases, this fails.  Somehow, the reprogramming of this
nucleus, which is what we're talking about, reprogramming it in terms of
its transcriptional program,  goes awry.  And therefore, bad
things happen.  The fact that on a rare occasion
gets and succeeds here already is extremely interesting because it
proves irrevocably that the genome of a mammary epithelial cell is in
principle competent to program entire embryonic development.
And that means that during the development of Dolly's mother,
we'll put her up here, as she developed from one cell into 1,
00 or 10,000 billion cells, as that development occurred the DNA
sequences that went from the fertilized egg to her didn't really
change.  I.e. the DNA sequences that were in one of her mammary
epithelial cells were intact,  and as capable in principle of
launching the full-fledged development as would be
a fertilized egg.  And that is one of the proofs,
by the way, that in fact differentiation does not involve,
with some rare exceptions,  alterations in DNA sequence.
This, in turn, ends up being connected with the whole issue of
embryonic stem cells.  Let's say that I wanted to have my
muscles regenerated,  although they're still pretty good.
So, I take a skin cell of mine, and I inject the skin cell.
I take the nucleus out,  and I inject it into an oocyte.
And then I let the oocyte develop up to this stage.
And I don't put the oocyte back into a sheep or another woman,
although I could in principle.  I actually take the cells out of the
inner cell mass.  Those are ES cells,
and I begin to use them to regenerate my muscles to do this
strategy.  So,  the cells are, in this case,
not used for reproductive cloning,  which is what this is here.
They're used for therapeutic cloning,  where instead of taking these cells
and the ES cells and allowing them to form a whole embryo,
they're used to form a cell line of ES cells from the blastocyst from
the inner cell mass.  What we talked about before,
here you see the blastocyst with the inner cell mass here.
You see it again.  But now,  rather than allowing this blastocyst
to continue development,  we simply extract cells from it and
again create ES cells.  I could create therefore in
principle, ES cells,  which are genetically identical to
all the cells in my body,  and any one of you could as well.
And here, there's not only one, but there's two ethical complications.
First of all, here we're starting human life with the intent of
truncating it very early,  and secondly, where are the oocytes
going to come from?  Well, you could say you can get
them from some women,  but producing oocytes from a human
female isn't so easy.  You have to inject her with all
kinds of stimulatory hormones,  choreogramatatrophic hormones.  It's
an unpleasant procedure.  Usually women are paid $5,
00 or $10,000 to produce some oocytes.  Well,
you say, that's OK,  but is that OK?  I don't know.
Is it OK to pay a woman to donate her oocytes to make herself into an
oocyte factory?  I don't know.  You have to judge.
I think there's arguments both for and against it.
Clearly, any one of us would be extraordinarily naÄ«ve if we thought
that this was a procedure which had no ethical encumbrances in it.
And, you have to think about them for yourself.  Still,
the potentials are enormous,  and therefore the question exists.
Will there be ways in the future of taking differentiated cells from
one's tissue, and in fact using them in these ways to make ES cells
without having to go through an oocyte, and without having the
potential of creating human life.  The alternative to this has been to
do the following,  to go into our normal tissues and
pull out adult stem cells.  What do I mean by adult stem cells?
These are not stem cells that are totipotent.  These are stem cells
which are in my muscles and regenerating muscle mass,
which happens believe it or not.  These are stem cells which might be
in my skin and are continually regenerating skin cells.
Keep in mind that in the maintenance of all our normal tissues there are
stem cells whose configuration can formally be depicted like this with
the transit amplifying cells we talked about before.
And maybe, if one took the stem cells out of an adult tissue right
here, if we had a way of extracting them, those could be propagated in
vitro, and then injected back in.  Those are so-called adult stem
cells.  And the individuals who are against
this kind of manipulation of human embryos and so forth say that adult
stem cells are really the solution.  You take stem cells out of a
person's tissue,  you expand them.  Ex vivo means out
of the body, in vitro,  and then you use them.  You inject
them into somebody's tissue to regenerate their tissue.
There's only one problem with that.  It's ethically far less encumbered
obviously, but it doesn't work that well.  In fact,
some people think it hardly works at all, that the exceptions are really
rather far and few between.  And so, this issue will long be or
continue to be debated.  But it obviously represents a very
new and exciting area of biomedical research.  And interestingly enough,
it impinges as well in a fully unexpected way on cancer because
this whole paradigm of stem cells,  it turns out, also applies to cancer
cells.  If you were to have asked me two or
three years ago,  what did the cells in the tumor look
like?  I would draw a picture like this, that these are a series of
exponentially growing cells so that all the cancer cells,
all the neoplastic cells in the tumor mass are biologically
equivalent to one another.  They all have the same mutant
genome, and they all are capable of multiplying exponentially.
But it turns out that work in the Matavoidic system on Matevoidic
tumors like leukemias,  and now on breast cancers,
yields a very different results,  because it turns out that the way
that the tumors are organized looks like this.  The tumors also are
organized in this hierarchical array just like normal tissue.
How do we know that?  Again,  I'm glad I asked that question.
Because if you take these cells out of the tumor and put them in another
mouse, let's say,  you get a new tumor.
These cells are tumorogenic,  I.e. they concede a new tumor.
If you take these cells out of the tumor, they have the same mutant
genome.  They constitute the bulk,  the vast mass of the cancer cells in
a tumor.  You put these into a mouse,  and they're non-tumorogenic.
And, in some kinds of tumors,  the tumorogenic cells can represent
only 1 or 2% of the total mass of cancer cells in the tumor.
And from this,  we begin to realize that you look
inside tumors: the tumors deviate minimally from the organization of
normal tissue.  They also depend on self-renewing
stem cells which can make transit amplifying cells and can give end
stage cells, which although they're neoplastic, have many of the
differentiated characteristics of the normal tissue from which they
arose.  And this has enormous implications for,
for example, therapies against tumors.
If you ask somebody,  how do you develop and how you judge
the success of an anticancer treatment?  You talk to somebody
like from the pharmaceutical industry.  And let's say that's easy.
If you have a new drug,  and that drug reduces the mass of a
tumor by 50%, that means that you've done something really good.
But let's look what's going on here.  If these cells are 99% of the tumor
in terms of the mass and these cells are 1% of the tumor,
let's say you've invented a new drug which wipes out all of these cells
but doesn't touch these cells.  The bulk of the tumor has shrunk and
everybody will say,  eureka, we've succeeded in curing
cancer.  But keep in mind that the self-renewing capacity of the tumor
rests in these cells.  And if these cells are allowed to
survive, then they'll start proliferating again and regenerate
the entire tumor mass.  And you won't really know that you
had any success because these cells look like all the other tumor cells
under the microscope.  But biologically, they're very
different.  And therefore,  the future of cancer therapy,
and it will take five or ten years to do this, has to begin to focus on
getting rid of these self-renewing stem cells which create this
enormous regenerative capacity on the part of tumors.
See you next Monday.  Have a great vacation.
Eat much turkey, and get some exercise, and don't smoke.